my first guests are the stars of the
billion-dollar blockbuster franchise The
Hunger Games the final film The Hunger
Games Mockingjay part 2 hits theaters
November 20th please welcome Jennifer
Lawrence
[Applause]
[Music]
that's right I know that's insane
Wow I want to tell people watching right
now I had the pleasure of hosting a
panel with you guys just a couple of
hours ago here at comic-con that fan
intensity is like nothing I have ever
seen before
it is absolutely incredible and it
here's the other thing here's the other
thing
that was
wait that was that was clearly for me
but here's my question it's
international is there a country or
place where you remembered it got almost
out of hand like it's one thing here in
America it's one thing in this country
that country is there one country you
guys went where you thought this is this
is too much
Spaniards and Italians are very
passionate a couple here yeah when we
when we went to Rome
they had military police with full
machine guns with barriers holding back
12 year-old Italians shoot our fans no
no no never don't worry but they're
really had military police holding
people back and there was one point
where we were down the carpet we were
almost finished and and I look back I
look back I look back and I saw I saw a
barricade fall over and I was like I
just my mind just flashed like a horde
of Italian hunger games ban is just like
like sprinting at us it was that this
time where I've really seen like an
actual wave of people coming at me yeah
like coming over the top of each other
like it was like really walking over
each or just taking them out and then
there's it it became a real Hunger Games
is what yeah you guys were hunted
through the streets of Rome yeah you
know it's interesting there's such
intensity today at the panel there are
people who are team Peter team Gail I'm
curious do you ever have people who come
up to you and they tell you that they're
not on your team
that they're on a different team do you
know I mean I'm sure you get a lot
people that say oh hi I'm team Gail I'm
team Peter but you must have people that
sometimes come up to you and say no I'm
not on your team oh yeah I mean for me
that's weird because they always like
you know this is an omen or actually oh
I can take a picture of that quota and
you meet the person and then they always
do at the end they're always like I'm
team Gail by the way put it in a way it
kind of feeling that way it's like
they're getting like I'm gonna just give
you one little stab in the heart real
quick and then get out of here as long
as they get what they want and then they
do it that I guess I guess or or they
say I've actually never seen yeah
you know but but but my daughter has so
I'd love to take the photo my favorite
things when they're like I'm sorry they
say you're famous I have no idea who you
are can we take a photo I'm like I don't
think so man well man it is you ever get
this where they call other people like
they call someone else who works at the
deli counter they go do you know who
this is so it's very loud I do not know
who that is and you're standing there
and they're like come on you don't know
who this is
yeah and they ask you to tell them the
movies you're in yeah they're like tell
tell them tell them who you are
long walks on the beach you say you're
hiding out all the time I am Jessica
Chastain